but let's talk about this very very
serious development yeah
i got to be honest so first of all
here's the story from az family
governor ducey says he won't accept
election results until all lawsuits are
settled
they say during a press conference was
the first time we heard from
uh governor doug ducey since the
election several reporters asked him
about the debunked conspiracy theories
in arizona like sharpiegate
and if he accepts the election results
in arizona ducey made it pretty clear he
will not
accept the presidential race election
results until after
all of the court filings are resolved
and until every vote is counted
on the one hand the governor said we can
trust our elections here in arizona
but minutes later he said there are
questions and those questions should be
answered
these are legal claims that are being
challenged in court once those are
adjudicated and the process plays out i
will accept the results of the election
ducey would not acknowledge
president-elect joe biden as the winner
in arizona
but rather is holding out after several
lawsuits were filed by the trump
campaign and arizona gop
some which have already been dropped
those challenges will play out in court
and then i will respect the results of
the election but at the same time the
governor spoke
party chairs were inside the maricopa
county election center certifying the
accuracy of the election equipment
which matched up 100 percent for the
third audit
but arizona republican party chair kelly
ward came outside
to hold her own press conference calling
for a full hand audit of the election
who has access to the usb or the drives
that are used in the machines
who programmed the machines all of these
are very important as to what's going on
in the electoral process we need to know
these answers ward said
maricopa county democratic chair stephen
slagaki
said ward is putting on a show and it's
frustrated anybody is still trying to
prove
any issues the deduction process he said
all right here's a quote i'm assuming
it's from him
here i am at the elections department
right now testing the machines testing
the equipment they matched up exactly
100
and then literally kelly ward goes from
this room and then goes outside and
trashes the process that we just
certified as being accurate
we have verified the vote we have
verified the machines
there was no fraud here no discrepancies
i'm gonna stop right there and just say
in georgia there's there's several
things that kind of were crazy
three counties where they uncovered
votes that were not tabulated
more importantly several sworn
affidavits from both republican and
democrat alike where they said some of
these ballots were
pristine no creases and it looked like
the vote for joe biden was like
machine printed like a perfect just
stamp right into the
you know dot for joe biden so it's weird
when the democrat when the republicans
are saying we want a hand audit
of these votes because you would see
then if you're looking through the votes
you're like that's
printed on a printer you would notice
right away so for them to be like no no
don't worry the machines say they're
good we're done to me
it's kind of strange can't they do tests
to find out if it was for instance
ink from a printer or toner from a laser
printer let's say you'd have to do a
hand audit
yeah i guess but not like the democrats
are resisting this every step of the way
yeah of course you'd think they'd be
like okay fine if we do this will you
accept the results
instead they're like no we don't have to
investigate
this was really interesting to me this
is actually a question that i asked on
twitter because rem
you remember that gop guy who won like
they did a recount or something they
come up
with a thousand extra bouts why wouldn't
democrats then
want recounts of all of this that's why
because
the race flipped for the republicans so
yeah do
you hear about what happened with this
guy in michigan he was of today no this
was like last week or whatever this
guy's a republican
and they announced he lost or whatever
the vote came in and he said i wasn't
going to call for a recount or anything
and i just accepted the results and then
he got a phone call saying oops
there was a glitch you actually won
and the republican actually ended up
winning and so this led to
more scrutiny and then we saw a
republican noticed that
6 000 of trump's votes were registered
for biden and then said it's a computer
collection they said no no it's human
air it's human error
so we have we have all of this uh
widespread voter irregularity stuff
going on
and uh it's it's definitive at this
point the media is gonna say no evidence
of widespread voter fraud that's a very
very specific thing and hard to prove
widespread and fraud proving fraud
is hard we can prove that people's votes
aren't being counted
that they're finding a bunch of you know
missing ballots and that it's widespread
i think we've done that at this point i
would think that the americans would
want
to verify the american election at this
point
regardless of political are you saying
that democrats aren't americans i'm
wondering if they have america's best
interests in mind if they want to
you know steamroll an election that's a
great question
well there was a meme going around of uh
they were saying like hey guys trump is
trying to steal the election
quick we have to do hand recounts yeah
frame it as we've got to stop trump
right and i think if
if people were led to believe that
that's the only way to verify that trump
lost
they'd go for it we should i think we
should that is the only way for them to
verify trump lost
and i wonder why then they're saying no
to it just accept the results as they
are because they believe they already
won so let's
run the clock here's here's the thing
trump is
potentially going to win now you have
arizona so i don't know to what extent
the governor can like block the
electoral certification i have no idea
maybe he can't because the state
legislators that decide ultimately where
the electors go
but this does throw az into some kind of
question
may not actually be that impactful but
we also have
uh michigan where these two you know
this two county
uh canvasser or these two board
canvassers said we rescind our votes we
don't want to certify
so if trump does get close to winning
through
a contingent election right now is the
only opportunity for democrats to prove
trump lost by getting a full hand
recount in all of these swing states
and they're resisting it so
if i was on their side and i thought
trump was
satan i suppose i would do the same
thing i mean they are
sure that he is the next hitler right
they
have to stop him by any means necessary
and this is probably the most humane way
they can do it and we are sure that joe
biden is some kind of lurking
monster in the shadows who eats children
indeed i think he's being taken
advantage of my comments
my comment yeah i think my comics are
one thing but me as a person i just
think he
he had ambitions since he was younger
and his party is pushing him
and he probably uh he's kind of it's
like a car that's
i don't mean to sound cruel it's kind of
he's just kind of rolling down the hill
with the momentum but if he's a car in
neutral
i hate to say it that way but it's true
i feel like if you just
let him say what he was going to say
without coaching without you know
whatever
uppers he was on during the debates for
instance i don't feel like he would
nearly
he wouldn't have nearly as much momentum
as if people were kind of propping him
up and pushing him
shrun and nana shaba the pressure yes
that's the famous quote yes that and the
vatican
the magic words he seemed surprised when
he won the um primary
you got a little betsy climbing while he
was in the uh
i like that uh that my favorite comic
from you probably is i have it hang in
my office it's the one where uh joe
biden said 200 million people are going
to die
yeah the electricity yeah so but joe
biden literally said
it is estimated by the time i finish
this talk 200 million people will die
poor guy and then the comic you made is
and then it shows his like eyes glowing
and he's like and that time is now and
then he fires the
lightning bolts and the crowd is getting
like it's the best
yeah oh my gosh that's my favorite you
know it's
you have to wonder about uh joe biden's
like accidental statements when he says
like
we made the largest voter most inclusive
voter fraud organization in history
my goodness and then but then when he
also so if people think that he's
being if people think that he really
meant it and it was like a freudian slip
or whatever or like
he's losing his filter yeah okay so
people think that right
there are people who think he
accidentally admitted it because in his
old age right
yeah does that mean when he said by the
time i finish his talk 200 million
people will die
he really met it and he slipped he
slipped up yeah like joe biden is
planning on
foreign
he's been told about the great reset yes
yeah he was foreshadowing it
they're like all these people are going
to die in the pandemic and then he just
said it and they're like
you know you know what it really is i'm
sure uh there's like this grand global
conspiracy
and they're telling joe biden all of
their plans and using him as they're
like you know
he won't remember just telling him no no
no no he says it he just blurts it out
and then behind the scenes they're all
laughing like you know george soros and
hillary clinton they're like high-fiving
and they're like you just said it and
people just let him say it they're all
laughing
he just admitted to voter fraud and
nobody cares yeah
that's that's how sure of themselves
there and and uh what's betsy doing
oh come on that is so funny
it's kind of like a cause trouble it's
like the comics that george drew where
they're where george
uh sorry where joe is eating that little
girl and everyone is just
cheering like he never really has no
clothes and they're just cheering away
like what's going on so so this uh
this picture that's behind it's behind
george right now i don't think we can
see it yeah i don't think we can see it
uh it's a woman is handing a little girl
to joe biden while everyone's cheering
and then joe biden's mouth opens up like
a giant monster about to eat the little
girl who's freaking out but there's
everyone giving thumbs up and cheering
yeah and then after he eats it he looks
at the crowd and he's like he's a thumbs
up
it actually is a very very powerful
political statement because when
when joe biden said that you know it's
it he believes that
uh what do you say battlecat cares a
human right they cheer they're like yeah
when he says trinidad shabbat pressure
they cheer and i'm like what are they
cheering for
it's like those uh this is what is this
applause sign
going on yes we don't know what he's
saying just a plot but i don't
the scary thing is there's no applause
sign they're just mindless npcs going
yay
joe biden's like a freaking blah blah
and they're like yes that's what i
wanted this whole time
they're like pounding on the table
donald trump comes out and he's like
i'm gonna make more jabs lower
unemployment secure borders
hitler joe biden turning on a shop at a
pressure that's exactly what i was
expecting wanting to hear that's that's
that's what i'll vote for that it's kind
of like a weird
gladiator match where they just want to
cheer for their champion
to beat the other guy that's all it is
it's political gladiators
unfortunately they're like 70 years old
i think our leaders should be chosen by
blood sports is what i'm trying to say
so maybe like a hereditary uh
patriarchal
uh trial uh what is it called um
patriarchal hereditary combat trial by
combat
no not trial choose like no like you
know it was really funny that black
panther was considered this very
progressive you know
social justice movie but it's literally
about a king who's chosen based on
patriarchal heredity who has to fight
another man and women aren't allowed to
even try
it's an interesting if we want to go
into the subconscious of what they're
really trying to say with these stories
if that's even possible
with corporate storytelling uh it's it's
a weird uh
to unpack that is uh what are they
trying to save subconsciously what do
they even not
know they don't know what they're even
saying maybe
they're not saying anything you know
it's like it's the funny thing about
black panther was that the movie was
basically
what did uh sargon i think sargon said
this it was adolf hitler versus richard
spencer
because like to to to challah i was at
his name
he's all like it's our country our
borders we can't let anybody in
he even says in the movie like if they
come in here they'll bring their
problems with them
and so it was very much it was like
ethno-nationalist country hoarding its
wealth
but then the bad guy was like we should
give weapons to everyone of our race and
like take over the world so it's like
who is the good guy in that movie i
guess at the end t'challa goes to one of
the wealthiest nations in the world
and and goes to one of the richest
cities in california and gives
people stuff i just thought that was
really hilarious they're like they
decided to open up their country to help
people
so he goes to what do you go to oakland
it's like i get oakland's got problems
but like it's still the bay area you
know what i mean like
it's still pretty wealthy anyway we were
talking about voting
and i was going to talk about this
evidence and then we got sidetracked can
i interject something here that just
came up on my phone
so it looks like georgia's uh finished
their hand audit and they have confirmed
it for
biden and the other thing i have on my
phone is that the ap
has declared joe biden the winner in
georgia after the state election office
said that the hand tally
about well you know maybe it's all over
and donald trump's gonna not be
president i don't know there you go
that's what i thought yeah in 2016.
as of 2016. yeah and then he was
president yeah and now
i don't know i kind of feel like we're
gonna have two presidents
you know what though i don't i wonder if
you get the same feeling
do you think trump voters would be as
angry as the left
if they lost no but i feel like that's
that and there's been surveys about that
because we're just like oh well that
sucks yeah most people
but i also think that the the die hard
trump supporters especially the people
over like say like the donald dot win
are much more i don't the right word is
fervent
yeah they're uh like joe biden is going
to destroy this country
he's going to he's going to enforce the
lockdowns fauci is saying normalcy won't
return for a year
and what's happening is all the big box
stores and the big corporations are
getting all this money their stock value
is skyrocketing
and small mom and pop shops are being
destroyed and joe biden says
you know i'll lock down if they say to
and then osterholm who's the guy who
says to that advisor to biden says oh
we're going to lock the whole country
down
and then fauci goes no no no no no
we're not going to lock the whole
country down but there will be lockdowns
and we won't return to normal until
quarter quarter two or quarter three
that's going to wipe out small business
yeah it's going to destroy the economy
of this country
and leave us very very
uh worse off to put it mildly it's trump
won't do that trump do the opposite
yeah i mean none of us can know the
future but it's interesting to think
like
all right so even in my area where
there's a lot of chain businesses
they're closing most of their stores too
yeah they just
i don't know the money's not coming in
people don't want to work there anymore
um who knows what kind of is everything
going to be delivery nowadays like
amazon yeah
god knows i've been using them too but
like it's
i i need to go outside for my own health
i go shopping just to go out shopping i
put on stupid mouse so you're trying to
kill grandma it's what you're saying
maybe it's it's too bad that
they're so humans are not built for
being in pods
and uh i feel like uh
depending on how conspiratorial i want
to be i i can feel alex jones's energy
in the seat
oh yeah it's just maybe this is like a
test and they're trying to see
how far you can push humans into society
and like see can you keep them in their
houses and see what happens
i see the tinfoil right there yeah but
but
they we know they're talking about the
great reset we know that they've been
advocating for it
all year are longer than this the book i
think was written in 1996
by claude schwab and uh it was like
earlier this year they were like we need
a great reset
now they're basically saying we gotta
lock everything down even though it's
not proven to do anything at all
like we locked down nothing happened
everything got worse right okay so
lockdowns clearly don't make sense
and it seems like it just makes it just
fits with the grace
great reset plans it sounds like they've
said covet 19 is their opportunity to do
this
they're telling us literally what
they're doing yeah covet 19 popped up
and they said
all right let's do it let's uh let's
let's use this as a pretext for a
lockdown to destroy
wealth and ownership because one of the
goals of the great reset is that people
won't own anything
what's gonna end up happening is this is
gonna be like a 45 year old dude who
owned his own you know hardware shop
he goes out of business completely now
he owns nothing then they're going to
make you dependent upon the government
with these stimulus packages
and then all that money is going to go
to amazon and we're going to have like
three major corporations that supplies
with our goods
yeah well whether or not that was
intentional that certainly seems to be
what's going to happen if we keep going
down this track
some people want to stop it we maybe you
know some people who
have read a few books say hey maybe we
shouldn't go down this direction
this is where it could go maybe we
should kind of slow the train down if we
can maybe
i don't know hedge our bets that's why i
like the idea of states all having their
own rules we shouldn't do this whole
federal i don't like
joe biden's plan of across the whole
country we all have to wear masks
every state every even county has
different rules
depending on density of population
density and well there lies the big
problem for a great reset
republicans saying no we won't lock down
and democrats saying yes there's no
uniformity
how can you have a great reset when
there's a constitution and
states getting involved you can't
yeah like a mediocre reset media not
actually great the so-so race set
yeah what's yeah i'm a fan of states
rights i don't like the idea of
the federal government swinging it's uh
what's the word mandatory mandate so
here's here's what i'm doing
giant mandatory mandate here's my
current thought process all right here
you go
uh i think it was just after the
election i said like
that night media is going to call it for
biden trump is going to overturn the
courts
then they're going to say trump stole
the election it's a very simple
prediction that just fits with like a
lot of what's going on
and i don't think it was that
spectacular but all these lefties are
like dude so dumb you think trump's
gonna win and i'm like i think yeah
absolutely i think it's possible and
there's a vox and atlantic and nbc have
all written about trump's
you know path now they're starting to
get scared and the propaganda's getting
crazy
reuters is like trump's latest scheme to
steal the win from joe biden and i'm
like but joe biden didn't win
like our are we we're not a popular vote
country
so like this idea that if the electoral
vote votes for trump trump didn't win
like no he literally did that's how the
constitution works and if he finds a
legal path to do it
but now they're writing stuff like crazy
so here's what here's what i'm worried
about right now
they already called it for joe biden
like crazy twitter's putting labels
everywhere
joe biden is the president-elect he's
not
literally not until he's certified but
you know until the electoral votes are
cast usually calling someone
president-elect is just like
it's it's it's a it's like a placeholder
an honorary title
no it's like it's a tradition we just do
it because the other person conceded and
so we're like sure fine it's you we get
it
give them some briefings you know yeah
but that's not the constitutional
process
the constitutional process is we on the
14th they'll make their vote
so for biden and the media to be like
claiming this over and over again and
refusing to back down
is quite literally them refusing to
accept the the
the process for the election it's a
conspiracy although
i wouldn't no it could be a standalone
complex but they're all conspiring to
make him the president collect to make
him seem like the president-elect could
be
complex but you have a bunch of people
coming together who said they came
together
well they're all saying the same thing
standalone complex right
do you remember the difference a
standalone complex is when people do
something
uh oh i said i'll do this a similar
thing but they're not like behind the
scenes being like
hey let's do this together so they're
all saying joe biden won
because they want joe biden to win and
it makes it look like a concerted effort
when it's just a bunch of people doing
the same thing at the same time
so that's that's more likely but
regardless what do you think is going to
happen
when you have the for weeks joe biden
won joe biden one ap says he won ap says
he won
and trump's like we're going to court
the the governor of arizona is like he's
we're not going to accept this until we
get the legal resolution that's the in
the constitution
trump is going through this in the
constitutional process whether he wins
or not is is not the point
the media is lying refusing to accept
the process
in of our government by coming out and
saying joe biden is the president-elect
they are literally
undermining the constitution and our
legal process that's crazy
and they and they keep pumping out more
and more propaganda so i think what
scares me right now i don't i don't know
what the probability this happens maybe
it does maybe it doesn't
maybe it's a lottery tickets chance
maybe it's lightning striking three
times while a shark jumps in the air
maybe donald trump overturns a few
states
they get frozen joe biden doesn't have
270 electoral votes
and then the electoral college uh
can't deliver so it goes to house
delegation the delegations are
republican for the most part they're
majority republicans so they vote for
trump
then trump comes out and says i've won
then all these democrats say no you
didn't
joe biden did he says look at the court
look at the electoral college look at
the delegations look at the supreme
court
then they're going to say trump is
illegitimate he didn't win and we know
it and trump's gonna say i am legitimate
i won and everyone knows it
and then the trump supporters gonna say
trump is right and the anti-trump people
are gonna say trump is stealing the
election
and then what do you think happens well
i don't even think they need to do that
i think they
people have been winding themselves up
for long enough already
that if you were to tell biden
supporters that he didn't actually win
or antifa they would throw a fit they
would freak out but i think berg out
i think in order for there to actually
so i'm not saying it's going to happen
but the worst case scenario would be and
it's been a lot of people were saying
we're going to get the scenario where
both declare they won
and we're already there now trump is
saying i won the election we'll prove it
but we're not it's not official for
either so
so biden can say i'm the president-elect
and people roll their eyes trump can say
i have one and the left laughs
but what happens when trump is certified
but the media declares biden and all
these people don't know
i was talking to a friend earlier and i
i said it looks like trump's plans are
working
to some degree like this this challenge
in in michigan that might block up the
certification
i'm not saying he's going to win and she
said what is this i'm not seeing any of
this
i'm not seeing any of this news so you
get people
who can't see any of this happening
because all they get fed is cnn
and cnn says it's over so they believe
it you're going to end up with
trump's going to be like i won and
they're going to be like but he didn't
win
the news said it was biden and they're
not going to actually look at the
electoral college results they're not
going to actually look at the supreme
court
they're going to have no idea because
cnn's gonna be like he didn't win nope
he's lying
it seems really irresponsible for trump
and biden both to be saying that they
won
when the the constitutionally neither of
them yes
are they both are they idiots are they
both stupid
well biden i think trump is doing it
strategically but it's a lie he's the
president he's lying
i think trump is doing it because biden
declared himself the victor so trump
responded he lied i'm gonna lie
too well it's just such an irresponsible
terrible thing for someone to do
joe biden they declared joe biden the
winner then joe biden said he won
and so trump had to push back but why
didn't he just say he didn't win where
it's under constitutional review
yeah yeah so am i crazy though because
he
trump is president until january 20th
period not according to facebook sorry
you're wrong okay
facebook says you're right that sign
then he is president but he didn't win
the election yet
his character as such is that he doesn't
like being undermined so
if someone raises the volume to 10 he
has to raise it to 11
and there is a certain point where once
you're past 11
you can't shout it's like an internet
fighting match if someone's like
yo fight me bro and the other guy's like
hey man i'm going to fight you all right
where are you living
where's your house let's fight you can
only
fight so hard online until it comes to
fisticuffs
until a guy shows up at your house right
so in a way
what we're seeing between the two
president uh candidates
is an online shouting match of come at
me bro
yeah yeah and it's not going to end in a
fist fight with them but it's going to
be their supporters having fist fights
as we saw on the street
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time